Speaker 1: Mitt Romney was asked now that
George Anthony divulged there. Santos
has been charged criminally with
multiple charges. What should happen?
And I love that Mitt Romney doesn't just say he
should resign. He says he should already have
resigned. And this is exactly the right answer.
I actually wish that there were more Republicans.
Some of them are going to come around now and
say, well, he should now resign. I wish more
people said what Mitt Romney says in this
short six second clip to CNN's Manu Raju.
Speaker 4: He should have resigned a long
time ago. He's an embarrassment to our party.
He's an embarrassment to United States Congress.
Speaker 1: Okay. So, yes, he should resign now.
And actually, Republicans in the House should
hold a vote and they should kick him out. But
the right take, as Mitt Romney has been, one of
the few Republican voices willing to say this,
is that he should have been gone a long time ago.
He never should have gotten to this point in time,
even in even prior to the actual indictments.
These Republicans seem very scared to just come
out and say it or they don't believe it, But
good for Mitt Romney for making that clear.